>> Laura: UNDER NEW CALIFORNIA
LAW, PEOPLE WILL BE ALLOWED TO
REGISTER TO VOTE AND IT WILL
HAPPEN AUTOMATICALLY WHEN THEY
OBTAIN OR RENEW THEIR DRIVER'S
UNLESS THE POLITICIAN SUPPORT
VOTERS, THEY STILL SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ARE
DANGEROUS WHEN THIS HAPPENS.
RAIN JUST YESTERDAY AND HE IS
ALLEGED TO HAVE AND ROBBED FOR
YOUNG WOMEN.
LET'S GET INTO THIS NOW WITH
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR ANN COULTER IN NEW YORK
AND HERE IS TO YOU WITH ME.
A FORMER DEPUTY NATIONAL PRESS
SECRETARY FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
JOSE, LET'S START WITH YOU ON
THIS.
REGISTERING PEOPLE TO VOTE WHO
ARE HERE ILLEGALLY?
SPEAK A BE CLEAR HERE.
IT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN APRIL.
VOTERS, IF YOU AREN'T IN THE
COUNTRY, YOU CAN GAIN A DRIVER'S
LICENSE IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE FEDERAL LIMITATIONS.
YOU CAN REGISTER TO VOTE IF YOU
ARE AN UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT.
THEY WERE VERY CLEAR.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR, YOU WILL NOT BE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE IF YOU ARE AN
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT.
>> Laura: WHY IS THAT THE BIG
CLOSET THAT'S ALL THERE IS?
YOU WILL BE ELIGIBLE THAT YOU
CAN'T VOTE?
>> ILLEGAL ALIENS ARE BIGGER
RULE FOLLOWERS.
EVEN BEFORE CALIFORNIA WAS
REGISTERING THEM TO VOTE, THEIR
BIGGEST ORGANIZATIONS AND
LEFTIST ORGANIZATIONS GENERALLY
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE 90s THAT
MANAGED TO STEAL AN ELECTION
FROM BOB THORNTON.
THEY FOUND HUNDREDS OF ILLEGALLY
REGISTERED TO VOTE WHO WERE
VOTED FOR.
ALREADY 60%, ABOUT 60% OF ALL
BALLOTS IN CALIFORNIA ARE SENT
IN BY MAIL.
IT'S NOT EVEN ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO
NEED TO GO AND VOTE.
DON'T WORRY, THEY WILL BE VOTED
FOR.
>> Laura: WHY DID TRUMP CLOSE
THAT VOTER COMMISSION?
WAS IT THE STATES WOULD NOT
COOPERATE?
THEY MADE A BIG DEAL OF IT.
THE LEFT KIND OF MOCKED HIM.
THEN THEY CLOSED IT.
WITH THAT BECAUSE STATES WANT TO
GET INFORMATION?
THEY COULDN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE?
WHAT WAS IT? PGH >> I'M NOT
SURE, BUT I DON'T THINK IT WAS A
GOOD IDEA, EXCEPT IT MIGHT'VE
BEEN MOVED TO AN OFFICIAL
INVESTIGATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S GIVING DRIVER
LICENSES TO ILLEGAL ALIENS,
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS SAYING IT SO
BURDENSOME FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE TO
GET THEM BY DEED IN ORDER TO
VOTE.
NOW, ALL LEGAL RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA REQUIRED TO NOW GET A
SECONDARY I.D. IN ADDITION TO
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE BECAUSE
OF A FEDERAL LAW THAT SAYS ALL
OF THE STATES THAT ARE ISSUING
PHONY I.D. LAWS, WE NEED A REAL
ONE NOW.
THERE IS NOW THE REAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE.
YOU HAVE TO GO INTO THE INNER
CIRCLE OF HELL AND REGISTER FOR
ALL OVER AGAIN.
WHEN YOU START GIVING THAT'S
ILLEGAL ALIENS, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE GRILL-REAL I.D.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT VOTING.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, BUT CERTAINLY
>> EVERYTHING SHE SAYING IS
FALSE.
THE REALITY HERE IS THAT THIS
WILL BE AND CEMENTED IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE, THIS IS
ABOUT DEMOCRACY.
IT'S ABOUT REGISTERING PEOPLE TO
VOTE.
THERE ARE 45 MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
VOTE, AND WENT TO GET THEM
REGISTERED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS
COMMUNITIES, IT'S ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Laura: EVERY TWO NEW
IMMIGRANTS UNITED STATES SPONSOR
ABOUT SEVEN FAMILY MEMBERS.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT SPOUSES
AND MINOR CHILDREN, THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN RESPECTED AND
TIME-HONORED TRADITION OF
AMERICAN IMMIGRATION.
WITH THE PRESIDENT IS VERY
GIVEN OUT EVERY YEAR, ANNUALLY.
MORE THAN 400,000 OF THOSE ARE
THIS KIND OF EXTENDED FAMILY
CHAIN MIGRATION.
I KNOW YOU ORIGINALLY CAME FROM
VENEZUELA OR YOUR PARENTS CAME
FROM VENEZUELA.
BUT THAT'S A MINOR CHILD WITH
PARENTS.
WERE TALKING ABOUT UNCLES,
COUSINS, MOST AMERICANS ARE
AGAINST THAT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A BIG PART OF
THIS ONGOING IMMIGRATION DEBATE.
WHAT YOU STAND ON IT?
>> WE CAN NEGOTIATE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE PRESIDENT
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
HE TOOK IT OFF.
>> YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMEBODY WHO IS ON OR OFF HOLD
ON?
TALK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
>> HE SHOWED ON THE GOVERNMENT.
WE KNOW THAT HE SAID BEFORE THAT
THIS WILL BE GOOD FOR AMERICA.
>> Laura: HE ACTUALLY WON THE
WHOLE DEBATE.
>> THE MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
KNOW THAT THIS WAS THE
GOVERNMENT'S FAULT.